OK.
I don't want to spend a ton of time on this,
but I want to cover two really crazy reactions
to the Biden Harris campaign sort of coming
together in the last 24, 48 hours that we've
seen.
The first is remember that wacky Fox News
host, former Judge Jeanine Pirro.
She sort of suggested last night that she
knows something about how Joe Biden is not
actually going to be on the ticket by November.
She suggests something is going to happen
to Joe Biden between now and November, although
she doesn't actually say what.
Let's look at the clip.
Well, I have a lot of thoughts.
The first thought that I have, Jesse, is up
for some reason.
I just have this feeling that Joe Biden isn't
going to be on the ticket.
I have a sense that something is going to
happen before the election and he's not even
going to be on the ticket.
So don't even ask me if he's going to make
the four years.
But let me just tell you a little bit about
what I saw.
So immediately the questions start.
Is this a death threat?
Is Jeanine Pirro trying to suddenly suggest
to her audience that someone do something
about Joe Biden?
Is this merely some kind of allusion to a
health issue she believes Joe Biden's going
to have between now and November?
Is Pirro merely drunk again and unable to
cohere during her program?
It's not totally clear.
The sort of most dangerous and sort of insidious
interpretation of this would be the stochastic
terrorism type situation.
Now, she's, of course, not saying anybody
should do anything, but the idea of stochastic
terrorism is that given a large enough audience,
if you plant an idea that something could
be done, that it becomes statistically likely
that you would influence one person to do
something there.
The first time that we discussed stochastic
terrorism on this program was back in.
I don't even remember what year when Glenn
Beck was ranting and raving about the Tides
Foundation.
He had all sorts of ideas and conspiracy theories
about the Tides Foundation.
And it actually led to a particular guy getting
weapons and was was stopped on the highway.
I believe I'm going from memory.
I believe it was in California on his way
to attack the Tides Foundation.
And, of course, Glenn Beck would not be held
legally responsible for that if the if the
shooting or bombing or whatever were to be
carried out.
But the guy who was on the way said, yeah,
I watchbox at the time Glenn Beck was on Fox
News.
I walked watch Fox News and watch Glenn Beck.
And it's it's sort of it's anathema.
It's a statistical thing where if zero point
zero one percent of an audience is likely
to actually do the violence that is implied
by a host.
If you have 100 people in your audience, it's
unlikely to reach the threshold of one person
going and doing something.
If you have a thousand people, it's unlikely.
But once you get to an audience of one hundred
thousand of five hundred thousand of a million,
two million, even a small likelihood of influencing
someone becomes likely to actually influence
one, five, 10, 15 people to go and carry out
an action.
So that would be like the most uncharitable
interpretation of what Jeanine Pirro is doing
here.
What what is unbelievable is that this is
happening on one of the country's largest
three cable news networks and it's happening
in prime time.
And at least as far as we know right now,
there is no repercussions for it.
There is no blowback whatsoever from the perspective
of Fox News.
Now, in terms of whether anybody would really
be able to do anything to Joe Biden, Joe Biden
has Secret Service protection.
Kamala Harris does as well now.
And Secret Service is good at their job in
terms of protecting people.
And I imagine that Joe Biden's safety is well
handled.
So that would point more to the idea that
she's floating of some kind of health situation
for Joe Biden.
So that's number one in terms of the just
wacky reactions to Biden.
Harris getting a lot of attention in the first
24 to 48 hours after the announcement of Kamala
Harris joining the campaign.
Let's now go to number two, which we are not
now.
But tomorrow I'm going to go to number two,
which is birther ism.
Birther ism is back.
It's less urgent.
So we will discuss it tomorrow.
But no shortage of that.
And, of course, birther ism with Barack Obama
was hugely racially tinged.
And what a surprise.
Lo and behold, Kamala Harris, whose father
is Jamaican and mother is Indian, now being
hit by very similar birther like questions
about whether she's eligible to be V.P. or
president.
Were she to be in a position to replace Joe
Biden.
And we're going to discuss that tomorrow.